393 people died yesterday and it
included the biggest daily increased so
far of people with no underlying health
conditions that means the total number
of deaths is now 1,800 and a increase
looks frightening but health officials
anticipate the number of deaths reported
each day will rise until the viruses
under control so how should we interpret
this increase well if you look at what's
being termed the rate of growth that's
the number of days that deaths take to
double that rate is still in the three
day zone it's worth remembering that
many of the patients whose deaths were
announced yesterday did actually die
more than a week ago so it might still
be a week or two before the impact of
lockdown shows in these figures we need
to talk about this in more detail don't
we're just gonna wander over here and
pick up my notes because I want to speak
to the the minister in charge and this
is going to be a tricky conversation
this morning mr. generic you chair the
you have chaired the daily briefings so
you know exactly what is going on let's
start with testing I think it's fair to
say that the government's starting to
lose public support mixed messages from
ministers then Corrections from number
ten let's use this 10 minutes or so to
clarify what's going on how many tests
did we do yesterday Monday we tested
8240 individuals this weekend
we tested over 900 NHS staff so we have
now begun to move away from testing
solely those who are in critical care
the patients in the greatest danger from
coronavirus to ensure that we understand
what condition they have and then can
treat them appropriately okay - testing
NHS staff and we just let deal with
let's deal with the facts this morning
should we understand the other stuff so
into 8240 people were tested on Monday
we said that we would get up to 12 and a
half thousand that's what the government
told us per day when give me a date when
is that going to happen well I hope it
will happen in
either today or tomorrow we now have
capacity to test 12750 people every day
we were focusing our the capacity to do
that we had on people in critical
conditions which was on medical advice
because that was the best way to save
people's lives so that hospital staff
could understand what the condition was
of those people who owned a dental care
and know how to treat them appropriately
yeah because we now have more capacity
clearly not as much as we would like but
we have more capacity we're now able to
begin to test NHS staff okay proceed we
you understand that we've got it you
tell us every day alone with your
colleagues plane we get it it's gonna be
a tricky conversation this morning let's
get on with it when we'll be up to
25,000 tests a day give me a date well
we said it would be hope to be in that
position by mid April we think within
days we'll be able to go from our
present capacity as I say of 12750 to
15,000 so that's a significant increase
but still not as far as we'd like it to
be and then mid-april is when we expect
to be at 25,000 but we now do have
enough tests and this an important point
strides made to text not just those
patients in critical care but to begin
to test NHS staff that's obviously
absolutely essential 15th of April will
be up to 25,000 a day Germany is testing
well they tested a million last week we
were told by your colleague Michael Gove
that there was a shortage of chemical
reagents which is why we weren't having
the number of tests that we had been
promised the chemical industries
association says that this is not the
case that it's not the case we have
enough of these reagents to do the tests
who is wrong you can't both be right
who's wrong well the position as I
understand it is that you need a number
of different ingredients to make an
efficient test and we have some of the
ingredients available in the
okay but not all of them and so we need
to bring together the right group of
chemicals and other materials to produce
the test we are trying to do that the
industry is doing a fantastic job but
this is a huge effort they're ramping up
supply we're importing materials from
overseas but I think as we can all
understand there's extremely high demand
internationally all other developed
countries want to be procuring these
tests at this moment because testing is
essential okay to providing an exit
strategy we know I'm asking you for the
numbers this morning please sir if I may
just the numbers we understand the other
stuff we've been talking about it for a
month
as far as nervous it is concerned they
produce these tests in the United
Kingdom they say it's not the tests it's
the facilities we don't have enough
facilities as a result they're exporting
these tests to 80 other countries
because we cannot do the tests because
we don't have the facilities is that
right or wrong I don't know but what I
do know is that we are working with as
many of the British manufacturers we
possibly can and seeking to import these
from other countries around the world as
I say demand is obviously very high for
these because everybody is seeking them
at this massive global pandemic that's
the nature of the situation we find
ourselves in but we are able now to
finally begin to ramp up supply we are
also doing some novel things like
creating a test where NHS staff will be
able to take it in the comfort of their
own home and then post it okay let's
stick with the questions this morning
please if I may we don't have time the
World Health Organization says Britain
is too slow the Health Protection Agency
is too slow to roll out these tests are
they right or are they wrong well the
World Health Organisation said overall
that they support our approach different
countries have taken different approach
to this and I think there's whilst it's
helpful to compare ourselves to other
countries
and we are doing that obviously there
are limitations to that because we have
chosen a particular path and different
countries will to make different
decisions in terms of the types of
people that they test and I think we
will obviously learn lessons later on as
to which country got this right but what
we're trying to do at the moment is get
as many of the tests before as we've got
an obvious I know I appreciate that it's
from a base that is lower than any of us
would wish we are now making significant
progress okay
so the World Health Organization is
wrong to criticize us will have is not
enough tests that we need by the 15th of
I'm just asking you straight questions
so if you can give me a straight answer
that would be great well I'm trying to K
but what I was saying was the different
countries are taking different
approaches we've taken ours on the basis
of medical opinion but what we're doing
now is working as hard as we possibly
can with the manufacturers that you've
mentioned and others to get as much
supply into the system as okay
and the important news in the last few
days is that we now have sufficient
capacity to begin to test NHS staff who
obviously deserve to know how they stand
and to be safe in the workplace as
indeed to all of those people that are
in lockdown that are listening to you
this morning we are only two-thirds of
what you promised that they would have
but let's see let's talk about
ventilators how many do we have today
well we have over 12,000 ventilators at
the moment and the good news that we had
announced yesterday was that the first
of the ventilators that being made by
British manufacturers these are
manufacturers who weren't producing
ventilators just a couple of weeks ago
before we put out the call for any
British companies to come forward have
now produced ventilators which have met
standards they've been tested and
they're now able to come into
circulation and to be used by the NHS
we've taken receipt of a small number of
them so just to clarify how many do we
have today
just to clarify how many do we have
today well we've taken receipt of 30 of
the new ventilators made by British
manufacturers they appreciate us a small
number but that's just the beginning and
we expect that over the course of the
next week thousands of these benefactors
British manufactured products
we'll be able to come online and go into
great new hospitals for example like the
Nightingale hospital in London by the
end of the week how many events is in
total we have or how many of the new
ventilate how many in total ventilators
available for people who need them by
the end of the week I don't have that
figure to hand K but we will have as I
say we think by next we will have
thousands more ventilators than we have
today okay you know these are bearing in
mind that just a few weeks ago we had
around 5,000 we have by the end of next
week by the end of next week you're
putting the orders in you must know well
how many will we have by the end of next
week well it's not quite as simple as
that because I know these companies have
never pretty well because these
companies have never produced
ventilators before and so with respect
we're asking them to do something and
they've responded amazingly by producing
products anyways the other didn't
existed a few weeks as many as they
recorded as many as these companies I
you know I need to finish my sentence
we've ordered as many as these companies
are able to produce and we believe that
they'll be thousands within the next we
do we need a big step forward according
to modeling how many do we need by the
peak well there are different
assumptions there but if we do need a
significant increase in the number on
that we have today we're obviously
building new hospitals like Nightingale
4,000 beds but neat we need to ensure
that has the appropriate equipment
alongside those fenced and I don't have
millions hundreds if not thousands of
more ventilators okay to be available
for mr. German let me ask you because
we're almost out of time let me ask you
about PPE we were told that the
everybody on the front line who needed
PPE had it then we were told yesterday
in the news conference that that wasn't
the case tell me geographically where
people on the front line are people who
are putting their lives on the line for
us geographically where do they need it
this morning and when are you going to
fix it
well we've delivered around 170 million
my question of PPE people on on the
front line and we've delivered those to
about 58,000 different well I don't know
what your question was you asked me
which let me ask you it this way please
if I may I know it's my last question my
question is this if you could just
answer it geographically we're diff
people on the front line need the
equipment today because yesterday you
said that they didn't have it where do
they need it this morning and when will
they get it well there's two elements to
that firstly public health England will
be publishing shortly guidance which
sets out what type of PPE different
people on the front line require to do
their job in a safe manner and that will
range from people in the most critical
situations in hospitals to other public
services like Social Care and their men
and women who you are a refugee examples
but they're poor and understand what if
I go to achieve PP the second point is
how can we meet the demand for it and
there are many places across the country
who are putting in urgent requests for
PPE we're doing that in a number of
different ways by having a PPE line so
if you're lips into the program and
don't have the supplies you need
completely and they should be able to
provide you with a delivery of PP as
quickly as possible we're also using the
military to move around the country the
supplies that we do have because in some
parts the country there is excess supply
awaiting the frontline where across the
country there's a legend where where we
distributed as efficiently as possible
well it's a very fluid situation I mean
for example just a few nights ago there
was a shortage in some settings in
London and yet there was also a large
supply in London so the military stepped
in and ensured that was distributed to
arrange the settings in London so we're
trying to create a much more efficient
system but distributing the very large
amounts of BP that are now flowing to
the people who actually need it this is
all
with respect as you said to me were 10
days away from the peak how can doctor
and medical staff on the front line not
have what is going to save their lives
how can that possibly be surely you have
to accept that you've failed but we want
to get everyone who's working on the
front line the equipment that they need
seemly hard to do that I think with this
challenge there is now a lot of material
flowing into the system what we're
trying to do logistically is ensure that
it reaches those people who are working
on the front line as quickly as possible
as I say we're doing that now working
with distribution companies with the
military who've been superb with a
hotline that helps even very small
settings like perhaps a small care home
to get access to the material by phoning
up and asking for it as quickly as
possible and also coordinating that on a
local basis who what's called our local
resilience forums where if there's an
emergency situation they can step in and
move material from one part of their
region to the net okay we do expect this
situation to improve quite rapidly
because there is a lot of supply in the
system albeit not reaching all of the
individuals who need it as quickly as
possible
util does it have been fixed and now
you've accepted that it hasn't looked
forward to speaking to you again mr.
Gerron I'm sorry that you are under fire
this morning but somebody has to be on
behalf of my viewers hopefully we'll
come back soon thank you let me know
your thoughts you can tweet me directly
if you would like to at Cape early